my mouse is acting on wed welcome to
this video my way I is playing the
Budapest I go with this yeah I have a
slight plus go against Tim plus 3 and
not great but well have to have to be
content sometimes if it those scores 16
out of 29 that's not bad k may be here I
mean 29 games just two drawers were
always fighting games 1395 year I think
he has to take that into account maybe
bishop evade
okay he went Bishop of it so let's edits
with that let's be quick here plano
moves 94 now it's my idea just attack
that pawn and win it probably Knight f6
0 or 1 i'd see if i 95 yeah it's one of
those ambitious moves looks shaky that
move somewhat for before I possibly
before
I wonder ever still should go 94 it
looks like it terribly one-sided
position but it's very lame an ID for
him 94 Queen takes Knight takes it's a
very lame way to play
hmm I just play something normally if I
could have done that 30 seconds ago some
normal
not exactly sure what I'm doing with
Queen D for maybe night h5 F for
something under by diagonal my 16 is
incredibly relaxed about all that okay
so
and night h5 is probably a silly move
but okay if he goes nighty six i have
Queen age for its kind of interesting
when he has not has never played g 60
night is somewhat annoying them
to not quite sure that one okay once to
play Bishop g6 I guess
yeah I wanted to go away for with all
that it's a risky probably somehow but
it's the way to make sense of the whole
set up a little bit at least I will get
into a terrible time to impression
95 °c Teague's
54 Bishop g4 95 Knight f6 check is quite
interesting I can defend I guess I guess
he can defend
and wow it's probably too good to be
true
I have an idea that is completely
bonkers you can sacrifice the Queen at
the end probably okay I'll still do it
cannot resist probably it doesn't work
at all but it's it's it's it's it's two
of two funny to not claim
cute chicks and I do this now this is
probably one of those things that don't
forget odd but ok knight takes Bishop g4
Bishop g4 Knight f6 check this is my big
idea with made on a jade at the end he
can probably give the Queen for all
kinds of stuff this is the that's
probably the reason why this is not
working can we can I cannot even count
this nice got Luke end to pieces or
something probably at the Internet okay
let's not working but it was just too
funny not to play all right it irritates
um at least I guess to take that I think
no
okay night before 94 the end he will
have a foregone yes great I don't
understand it so here he will have a
fork with c5 time I can you believe that
what a crazy way to defend and she's got
nuts it to coming and have to move the
rock
want to take you for finally and
blundering this damn bishop or come on
oh no thats it's kind of far I shouldn't
really lose that game anymore and I
managed to do it I might win on time
check no it was lucky black resigns I
was very lucky that it was a super way I
don't think that that worked what I did
here probably what he played dis refuted
as well it is okay here here that is a
very very sharp position I can tell you
what my idea was so I won't be form and
take a 95 and I think you can just take
it because my idea was the following
this this chair jack yeah and now I'm he
cannot defend the mate that is what I
saw when I went before it I this is the
problem he can just do this this is what
I mentioned that he got drew can't two
pieces so that is that was the
reputation of my I play I think what he
did is certainly playable but it um yeah
it is not as good the other other line
just wins 93 is good him here white is
probably winning yeah it doesn't have a
great square to go to where he goes
lucky i have f5 and currently I'm a
piece off he has to get one back in the
first place
so yeah and this isn't this isn't great
I mean I got out of it here I'm better
and then i blundered eat too I mean I
don't know not in good shape okay thanks
for watching